the internet and YouTube in particular
offers a vast ocean of content and if
you don't want to get lost or waste time
you have to learn how to navigate it hi
my name is Luca from Lucca and parado
calm and today I'm going to show you how
I use the Internet and in particular
YouTube to learn and improve my foreign
languages now specifically for
deliberate language learning there are
three criteria that are very good when
it comes to choosing your content the
first criteria is that you should abide
by content that is interesting to you if
something is interesting your main focus
is not the language itself but it's the
message and as a consequence you will
learn the language that is used to
convey that message the second crucial
factor or a point is that this content
should be comprehensible to you so you
don't want to choose content that has
maybe just two audio or in which the
audio is too fast and is not good
quality but instead you want to focus on
content that is very clear that is
possibly made for learners but not
necessarily and that has subtitles in
your target language and in English the
third important point to keep in mind
for what I'm going to tell you later is
that the video be a maximum of five six
minutes in fact if the video is short
you can focus on it better and you can
do a number of repetitions on it which
are going to expand the amount of time
that you're going to spend on the video
and if the video is say ten minutes then
it will take you 1 hour to do that so
but to be short keep it sweet thang keep
it effective
so one of the resources that you can
find in YouTube which satisfies the
aforementioned criteria is easy language
easy and garyun easy French easy Italian
you name it
there are multiple versions for multiple
languages and for multiple learners in
particular I have been learning and
garen for quite some time and I still
use easy and garen as a wonderful
learning resource so now let me show you
directly how I do it on my computer so
one recommendation as you can see here
on the screen you have the box of the
video itself but you also have to
consider that there's this column on the
right that shows you the other related
videos a very good recommendation for
avoiding distractions is to put it in
full-screen because what happens with
YouTube is that you have a lot of other
videos possibility you can watch but you
have to pay attention because those are
distracting the moment you start
watching the video your eye falls on the
other videos as well and you want to
change the video even before you finish
it so make sure that you have it on full
screen so as you can see we are in full
screen now and the presenter Justyna is
holding a microphone and she's going to
go around interviewing people on the
street which allows you to actually
enjoy how people really talk we're in
budapest here and this video is easy
Hungarian let's get started oh one
second before we start an important
thing is that as you can see I have my
piece of paper here is to write the
title of the video so you have here easy
and garyun and then the title of episode
1 and then to add the date this is
important for your episodic memory and
for your motivation and I'm going to
talk about this a little bit later so
let's get started is easy Hungarian
easytek mission YK Edition because it
would send buddy an egg but who does the
submission
[Music]
see us an escalation was that - I said
edit does me so the very first step that
I do is very simple I watch the video I
enjoy the video and i look at subtitles
as you can see you have subtitles both
in an Aryan and in English which makes
this video comprehensible and very nice
to look at but the first thing that I do
a step number one is to watch this video
in Hungarian and with subtitles in and
guarantee and why do I do that well
because I focus on the video itself on
the content itself it does not matter
how much I understand I'm focusing more
on the relationship between the spoken
language and the written language so
here they're talking and you know about
somewhere do you want to travel etc and
I finish watching the entire video once
then step number two is to rewind the
video as I'm rewinding it right now and
to watch it by focusing this time on the
English subtitles so let me watch this
again this time looking directly at the
English subtitles below my Edition
because it would send buddy and I but
who does the submission okay
after watching in a second time but this
time with the English subtitles I have
started understanding more and more of
the content because this is content for
I would say intermediate advanced to
learners it really shows how people talk
on the streets these people were getting
interviewed they don't know that they're
doing this content creating content for
learners so they talk very fast and they
use expressions that are commonly used
so it's normal that I will miss a lot of
stuff so after step 2 I already got a
better idea of the content but I still
miss a few things so you want to do
something else and it is to watch it
again watching it with Hungarian
subtitles so you're integrating the
whole thing and you're getting the whole
framework or the whole picture
see us and ask addition was that who was
that near L it was me much more what
does the bad limber what I started NIC
many of them with not valium with London
bazooka schlocky Aki shot okay so you've
watched it three times now one more
thing that I do that does make a
difference is that I jot things down I
always say you know the Romans used to
save air bubble and said sleep dominant
and I can't stress this enough if you
want things to stick use a piece of
paper or find somehow some way to save
the words or the expressions or the
information somehow on a piece of paper
so what I do is I watch the video for
the fourth time but this time I'm going
to stop it here and there and I'm going
to jot down and mark and then look up
the words that I find interesting
related to this video so let me show how
I do it so I go back I found the word
that was interesting there for D Thani
which is translating excusive word I
love and I can see directly the
translation no pun intended
below I've neat I'd need the internet to
translate this so to jump for date on it
so another thing that I do and I want
you to look at my position is that this
configuration allows me to easily use my
left hand to stop the video and my right
hand to write directly so I just need to
stop here and and write it and you want
to make things easier for yourself
because if you're an uncomfortable
position of your body then you have to
change the position of your body you
have to stop you have to go back this
way I just use left hand right hand it's
really straightforward and it go
really fast not your service Haram
knockin em a corner with my Gordon again
no chikara no premedia come with not
volume alone demoniac less time to them
with me they said that they consider him
back ratrock februa
one unit at Chicago a veggie Festa
okay so I've done step number one step
number two step number three step number
four and we are at step number five if
you want and some things are still not
clear the last thing you can do is just
to relax now now you got the contents
because you've seen in multiple times in
different versions you're adding variety
to your brain in each step serves a
specific purpose now I just watch the
video again you can choose which
subtitles or you can even watch it
without looking other subtitles to see
how much you understand but the idea is
that now you can relax and look at the
full content and focus on the message
and this is a very straightforward way
to look and extract information from a
very simple video which you can see is
four minutes it took me 30 minutes to
complete it 2530 minutes and that's the
reason why I was stressing the fact that
the length be 5 minutes or 3 minutes or
4 minutes because if you decide to
tackle a 10 minute video then this
exercise or training or whatever you
want to call it is going to become very
very long you want to keep it smooth you
want to keep it efficient and you want
to keep it smart
so I've gone through these five steps
and that's great I'm satisfied I've put
in the work but the truth is that my
learning session is not finished yet
there is one last point that makes a
difference what I do is I make sure that
every time I finish a learning session I
first put an entry into my logbook which
is in a Google Docs or online and on top
of that I also make sure that I save
these pieces of paper into a folder I'm
going to give it a label Hungarian or
easy and garyun and then every single
time that I finished I put this piece of
paper into the folder the reason why I
do that is because a folder is a
physical entity that you can actually
see and every time that you start
learning or finished learning a session
among Garan or any other language for
that matter I'm constantly reminded of
the amazing amount of work that I've
been putting every single day so if you
want to use YouTube as a fantastic
learning tool to learn a bunch of
languages you want to keep in mind the
following first you want to find content
that is short comprehensible and
interesting to you second make sure that
you break down your learning session
into multiple steps in which each step
serves a specific purpose and make sure
that you jot things down and you have a
good body configuration or body position
so that you can do multiple things
smoothly at the same time and third make
sure that you store the information and
every time you finish a learning session
you jot down the entry on your logbook
and you keep a piece of paper and you
accumulate pieces of paper into a
physical folder that reminds you of the
amount of work you put every single day
so there you have it if you want to
learn how to use YouTube to learn or
improve a bunch of languages please
don't forget to come to my website where
I have written an extensive article
about this very same matter you can find
a lot of resources a lot of other links
and there's going to be a lot of new
surprises in the next future so stay
tuned subscribe to my blog subscribe to
my channel if you haven't done so and
good language learning and see you very
soon
[Music]
[Music]
oh and one last thing if you have any
comments or questions please write them
below because I'm going to take the most
interesting and curious and funny ones
I'm going to come and then and reply to
them so stay tuned and please write
below
you